Anthony is there any other information
about this virus you gotta tell us dude
um we gotta get my [__] get buy more
masks and stay six feet away from each
other I gotta go buy a bunch of toilet
paper right now tell me yesterday yeah
yeah no there's gonna be zombies among
us and we have they get their own
pronouns
[Music]
anybody know what permafrost is oh yeah
what is it permanent Frost it's in the
tundra where it's like
Frost it's what you put in your uh
Christmas tree it's the layer underneath
the fresh fresh snow that's
it has fossils and [__] it's Kirkland
brand Frost I thought they put that on
Christmas trees to make it white
it's like in the North Pole during the
Ice Age It's so cold that it stayed icy
very very almost right it's a color yeah
it's for when the grandmas want the
curls just right
permafrost oh that sounds nice
uh permafrost is land that has been
continuously Frozen for two or more
consecutive years that's what I just
told you that's it that's exactly what
we said yeah thank you it's usually from
the tundra so it's like the JK fridge
super big correct it's like the inside
of the JK freezer it's bad there's so
much ice around there that's permafrost
defined dude you have two inches of
freezer space dude you can't even fit a
microwave burrito in there anymore you
don't know [__] on the auto uh walk
during the election me and uh Steve
bought a ice pick from Amazon
you're having a conversation we're like
you know if we just [__] clean the
freezer we'd have space we could yeah we
could have ice in there for days yeah
but we gotta go get a bag of ice every
day every time you open that freezer you
gotta do [__] like like Tetris to fit
all the [__] every time you open the
freezer you gotta pick up 16 old Frozen
things that are falling nobody's eating
you're not gonna hurt the permafrost are
you dude we're gonna find a
holy mammoth in there took a lot of time
to make that Burma Frost man I got a lot
of Spears you can use well you didn't
offer that one I didn't know pick on the
walk you heard it I was far away you
guys should get an ice pick you said
that out loud so many knives in here
okay so there's so many weapons a team
of European scientists have revived a 48
500 year old zombie virus I heard about
this why are they [__] doing these
things why wouldn't they want to revive
it or just had a [__] a pandemic and
they made the pandemic so now they're
gonna [__] doing this [__] no that
was China that's different China made it
officially okay under fauci's leadership
now we're gonna have the [__] zombie
virus holy [__] Alaska for [__]
decades or something what if that's the
antidote
yeah zombies zombies fauci is one of my
heroes though because I saw a
documentary that was sucking his [__]
[__] the whole time why was it on
Netflix it was like some [__] CBS
documentary was it his documentary he
made of course he was all over the
[__] thing
he's he's blowing himself you don't love
that tiny little man no did he do the
part about him sucking his [__] cozy
dogs before science yeah dude the
beagles man yeah so sad can't use
beagles was that in the documentary no
of course not we left that out love the
beagles album
um so they found the zombie virus from
the Siberian permafrost leave it there a
lot of Siberian General has been frozen
over for Millennia since the last ice
age there's literally still frozen areas
of Siberia that are from the Ice Age you
know there's parts of Siberia where it's
uh like negative 100 degrees holy [__]
people live there yeah and people live
there people live there yeah it's cold
as [__] and you guys were climbing on me
earlier for about antarcticans
but guess what people live in cold
aspect [__] places that's crazy it
doesn't mean you can clown on you for it
yeah don't climb on me there's some
parts of Siberia where in at summertime
the it's zero degrees oh that's nice wow
that's how hot it is zero over negative
100 comparison that's [__] crazy
pretty good it's a good deal that's why
I don't think Siberian Huskies are meant
to be in hot places too yeah but Jon
Snow and then made it really cool so a
bunch of like really really hip Asian
guys got a bunch of huskies in
California yeah but I wonder if they're
actually from Siberia it'll be weirder
if you got like a Husky and you lived in
like a hotter place like Vegas am I
right I don't know anybody has Huskies
in Vegas
you don't you don't have like a half
husky half Shepherd maybe half a half
maybe the German Shepherd is cool Vegas
gets cold as [__] though yo that's the
Husky Scott the shepherd's size for
summer right am I right well the summer
you gotta keep them in the AC yo I see
so many dogs with [__] boots during
the summer in Vegas dude right now I see
I see dogs wearing like winter coats and
[__] it's [__] hilarious in Vegas
yeah that's not even necessary it's cold
though it's like [__] 30 degrees at
night yeah Vegas brings it during the
summer Vegas brings it during the winter
time we have like three months of like
really really great weather and then
like we're back to the extremes brother
yeah I like it right now it's nice and
cold [__] love it I like cold I love
it year round yeah well la is pretty
cool too like our weather right boys
like weather out here is like sad and
your taxes are so good all right we're
talking about weather you can't talk
about taxes that's [__] up Nick's got
a point there dude you kind of jump [__]
what are you talking about what are you
talking about can you teach me about
Karma frosting Okay so as well as
sequestering greenhouse gases purpose
Frost contains an unexplored diversity
of unfamiliar microbes many of which
called extremophiles
I'm not too confused with pedophiles how
do you remember the distinction thank
you are able to survive through extreme
conditions yeah everyone knows that like
cyanobacteria dude
everyone knows that yeah yeah
who let this big kid in the room
everybody knows that dude why is it a
zombie virus now
dude shut up you cheat
what kind of chick facts are you
spitting why is it called a zombie virus
is it because it stayed alive for
billions of years I think it was able to
come back to life oh my God that's the
extremophile a virus bag they also use
harsh terms to describe things like that
aren't necessarily deadly yeah for for
news purposes like to scare the [__] out
of everybody well I'm scared does it
does it say what the virus does no but
flu-like symptoms I bet yeah you need to
wear a [__] mask
there's definitely a hot debate over it
because like like Bart sent to me in the
beginning
um it's like why the [__] would you
bring something like that back so keep
that if it's frozen keep that [__]
Frozen duh like destroy blah blah or
burn it but I will say in the defense of
science
you got it's like space exploration yeah
it's like going towards a frontier just
because it hasn't been gone to before
yeah but it's not gonna
up there and die or what about this the
idea of fighting fire with fire
sometimes unearthing and finding the
keys to a virus is what kills other
viruses not necessarily being like oh
this is a virus therefore it's only
death how about finding more cures
that's kind of that's that might be a
byproduct nah they're finding more
diseases well what about the idea this
is a zombie Vice if something can come
back to life can you find something in
this genetic makeup that brings other
things back to life that's not their
history they keep finding [__] and they
[__] ruins us okay I'm I'm out of
arguments that's it
burn the scientists
burn them
this is my submission find the cooler
[__] if I found a virus that's old I
would have just [__] burnt it with a
Zippo lighter yeah same get the [__] out
of here that's crazy how they just find
that in [__] nice
someone give me a [__] right now it's
a virus there you go [__] if
you're naked eye give me a Zippo and
give me two target bags not one too look
at this old ass virus
dude double knot on the top of the bag
yep throw in the trash that's how you
know it's bad good gone or you got to
put a sticker that has bad sign before
you throw it away that's good because
people gotta know hazardous materials
that's right Anthony Lee is there any
other information about this virus you
got to tell us dude um we gotta get my
[__]
[__] get buy more masks and stay six
feet away from each other I gotta go buy
a bunch of toilet paper right now tell
me yesterday yes no there's gonna be
zombies among us and we have they get
their own pronouns oh
well I remember I was watching the
episode of Walking Dead and there were
zombie rights people they believe that
they need to learn how to coexist and
then they got eaten oh that's funny good
that's funny so this doesn't really turn
people into zombies right uh it's hard
to say Do you believe in natural
selection
um Define natural slime I believe in it
but the world doesn't I think it happens
all the time in the world dude I feel
like Bart has a hot take waiting to
bubble out yeah just say it hot Cheeto
man no because we don't believe in it
that's all we have all this [__]
medicine instead of just letting
ourselves die who should die first
whoever is the luckiest I don't know the
luckiest whoever wins the draw because I
think like we try to stay alive but then
we don't believe in we're trying to
fight natural selection is what we're
doing yeah if we if we bring people back
to life if that's what this is I'm sure
it does that only I think that's a scam
dude I don't think we should be able to
be brought back to life you don't like
even if so like I choke on a pretzel
ball game and then like they heimlich me
or you Nick's like hey natural selection
guys let's [__] move along this guy
choked on a pretzel what an idiot am I
right guys he's not even dead he's still
choking he's like help me I would save
you I know the high one thank you that's
different so you don't believe in
National selection yeah because that'll
be natural selection kind of right yeah
but certain degrees that's that's tier
one natural selection so it's like
survival of the fittest unless you're a
dumbass in the moment yeah dude if you
[__] uh say you're um playing with
some fire at your house and then your
house blows up and you blow up with it
we're not we can't save you that's
that's that's too far that's too what
about like you live in Pasadena you have
like a gasoline yeah and if I lit a
candle and I blew up that's on me I
didn't smell the gas and I lit a candle
I I deserve to why are you trying to
light candles for exactly I can't
believe your dog lit your oven up dude
it's pretty crazy I can't believe it I
don't have a dog that's the [__] up so
the um main consensus on the uh among
the JK fans is that you accidentally
turned it on with your fanny I knew it
that's what I said I'll say this
I'm like Mr Rod look go ahead hold on
let me let me finish this let me show me
your fanny package we need evidence it's
always on it's never off I don't know
that's heavy when I'm in there I got
chains bro I got change just because I
need to feed the meter you got a bunch
of oven [__] covers no but yeah I've
oven mitted here but when I come home
well the reason why I say I'm like Mr
Rogers I have a little routine take my
shoes off put my slippers on sing like a
pedophile just kidding dude he's not a
pedophile bro I know he's he's a um
extremophile then I take off my fanny
pack and I hang it and I [__] hang it
I hang it you hang it really what do you
mean you're hanging I hang it on a chair
that's one of the weirdest things I've
ever heard dude
I might have a hook on the wall you're
literally you have a hook on your wall
your fanny for my key this is where my
keys are you don't walk around with the
fanny pack at home I think you should be
federally investigated that's ridiculous
you don't walk around your house you're
a fanny pack dude nobody has a fanny
pack hanger nobody all I do is when I
get home I flip it so this doesn't get
in the way dude I take it off as soon as
I go home he has like seven fanny packs
so you're not chilling here well
sometimes yeah how come you don't take
it off here that's weird yeah it's not
comfortable here you need a home fanny
pack where you transfer your stuff and
put it inside yeah just like how you
have home slippers you need a home stop
being [__] weird you're so weird
just stop throwing stuff at me you guys
oh God come on man you guys can't keep
fanny pack off take your fanny pack off
here take it off relax
take it off
[Music]
foreign